Conor McDavid currently redot and on a nine game
point streak and the one 18-year-old many field
will one day be that next Unstoppable Force
for the first time Conor McDavid and Connor
Bard meet in this first Connor versus Connor
matchup in Edmonton all Odes are on 97 and
98 so these two guys would be considered
generational talents and we should not
throw that turn around Loosely but they have
proven that they can follow suit with all the
hype that's adored them since they were just
well kids and Conor Bard's the latest number
one overall pick to get to the National Hockey
League we're looking at two premier offensive
players it's a magical night this is a playoff
atmosphere when you consider 97 versus 98 in a
town that was made famous by 99 now McDavid hen
Hopkins and Hyman are on the ice against Conor
[Applause] bard
I saw you guys talking to him here's Bard off
the stretch quick shot the scores over the left
shoulder of Stuart Skinner and Conor Berard has
his 12th of the Year Chicago strikes first it's
one nothing and one of the men they came to see is
on the board and this crowd here is pretty quiet
cuz they just went wow what did we just seeing a
lot of talk about this kid shot for good reason
you're going to see it right here how fast he
can get this Puck off not only the quickness the
power but the accuracy takes the outlet pass
goes underneath the Stick of that who closes
quick pushes him to the backand but he brings
it backand to forehand and it's a lightning fast
release watch this forehand B up over top of the
glove I have to say it was better than I expected
that was some kind of release Bard and McDavid at
Center Bard who came in 40% on brw this year s in
deep off the face off contr by Evan buar whipped
up the right hand side McDavid Cuts in shoots and
that was a CL save for Peter barzik similar type
of release and don't think for a minute McDavid
wasn't trying to answer turned it over EV Bard
the steel the clear to Center nen Hopkins rolls
itead for McDavid back in front new Hopkins scores
the time goal McDavid extends his point streak to
[Applause] 10
pass picked off by courage and a nice little
Outlet to Conor Bard who opened the game
scoring but this time his shot smothered by
Echo here's the spin AMA look at the distance
covered by McDavid on that spin trying to go
around the big man 6'6 vasic here's Bard watch
this one-handed move tries to hook it back to
himself one-handed and spin at the same time
that would have been a beauty when you asked him
to he's got four in 14 games this year McDavid
whistles one just wide the glov side buar with
less than a minute to go on the period Edmond
hit it's first lead of the night 21 McDavid
splits the fence loads it up Waits curls it
back to at looking for a better opportunity
feel a lane was there board's pass stolen by
Kev he nudged it ahead for Conor Bard who wisely
and prudently clears back to Center still has it
back to the point Nick Felino on the ice now
dreed G shot save by Skinner and tight theard
Nick you're a veteran of over 1100 Games part of
your responsibil ities here with the Blackhawks
is to help Conor vard become a professional but
I'm wondering what you've learned from watching
your 18-year-old teammate you know he's taught
me just how bad he wants it how bad he wants to
be the best and and he won't stop at anything
it's uh pretty refreshing to see a kid like
that and the fact that it was just 8 years yeah
blink you mean here's McDavid dropping it off
whoar back to McDavid in front back H dened
what a save made by Peter mzik and that was a
terrific look I think kman was surprised that pu
poun out to him absolutely Stone zackman MC DAV
got through Gman shoots and a save oh there they
are head to-head power play winding down here's
dry Sidle he scored tonight Nan Hopkins has one
as well here's McDavid he assisted in the newon
Hopkins goal in front score that was easy McDavid
to Hyman just tap it in and then the perfect pass
right to the table eight multi-point nights in
a row for Conor McDavid got 28 assists and 24
games and the Oilers win their eighth in a row
in Conor versus Conor volume one goes to McDavid